La gente me dice que soy buena persona ...
al punto de que ya es parte de mi identidad personal y profesional.
Y que soy tan buena que me llevo bien con todo el mundo,
incluso con mis peores enemigos.
Es como mi "característica", eso que me identifica.
(Risas)
Pero lo que nadie sabe
es que yo acosaba en la escuela.
En realidad, nunca lo analicé demasiado.
Durante años, mantuve esos recuerdos enterrados,
pero aun así, gran parte sigue siendo difusa.
A propósito, la negación sería otra de mis características.
(Risas)
Pero cuanto más me alababan
por ser una liberal que podía llevarse bien con los conservadores,
cuanto más escribía sobre lo que es ser buena persona
y cuanto más hablaba sobre el tema,
tanto más sentía esta hipocresía crecer dentro de mí.
¿Y si en realidad era una mala persona?
Cuando tenía 10 años,
había una niña en mi clase, cuyo nombre era Vicky.
(Suspira)
Y yo la atormentaba
sin piedad.
En realidad, todos lo hacían.
Incluso los maestros la hostigaban,
lo cual no es ningún atenuante, ¿verdad?
Vicky era sin dudas una niña con problemas.
Se autolesionaba hasta hacerse sangrar la nariz
y tenía malos hábitos de higiene,
muy malos hábitos.
Pero en lugar de ayudar a esta niña,
que evidentemente tenía problemas en su vida,
le pusimos un apodo: "Vicky la pringosa".
Yo le puse ese apodo.
El recuerdo más vívido que tengo es el de estar parada en el pasillo vacío
afuera de las aulas de quinto grado
esperando a que Vicky saliera del baño.
Yo tenía un bloc y un bolígrafo para hacer una encuesta que inventé
sobre las preferencias en el uso de champúes,
una especie de investigación para la clase de ciencia.
Cuando Vicky salió del baño,
me abalancé sobre ella y le pregunté qué champú usaba.
Ahora bien, para ponerlo en perspectiva,
no recuerdo el nombre de mis maestros,
ni de ninguno de los libros que leímos ese año,
en realidad no recuerdo nada de mi quinto grado,
pero sí recuerdo que Vicky dijo que usaba el champú "White Rain".
Como si fuera ayer,
como si recién hubiese ocurrido.
Y cuando todos salieron de la clase,
corrí por el pasillo gritando:
"¡'Vicky la pringosa' usa champú 'White Rain'.
No usen ese champú;
si no, olerán como '¡Vicky la pringosa'!".
Borré ese recuerdo un largo tiempo.
Cuando después empecé a acordarme,
inmediatamente necesitaba saber más.
Contacté a amigos, intenté en las redes sociales,
hice todo lo posible para encontrar a Vicky.
Necesitaba saber que estaba bien,
y que no le había arruinado la vida.
(Suspira)
Pero enseguida entendí que lo que buscaba en realidad
no era saber lo que le pasó a Vicky,
sino lo que me pasaba a mí.
Cuando tenía 10 años,
traté a otro ser humano como un ser inservible ...
como si yo fuera mejor que ella,
y ella fuese una basura.
¿Qué buena persona hace algo así?
Es decir, sé que yo era tan solo una niña,
pero no todos lo niños lo hacen.
La mayoría no lo hace, ¿verdad?
Entonces, ¿y si yo no era tan buena a fin de cuentas
y era en realidad un monstruo lleno de odio?
Luego empecé a notar estos impulsos de maldad en mí,
a tener estos malos pensamientos
y a querer decirlos.
Debo admitir que la mayoría de mis malos pensamientos
estaba dedicado a los conservadores.
(Risas)
Pero no solo a los conservadores.
Me descubrí pensando cosas malas sobre los liberales blandos, de centro,
y los ambiciosos banqueros de Wall Street
y los islamofóbicos
y los conductores lentos,
porque de verdad odio a los conductores lentos.
(Risas)
Y cuando me descubría en estos momentos de hipocresía,
era porque los notaba más, o bien porque eran cada vez peores,
especialmente en los últimos años
Y cuanto más odio sentía,
ira, en realidad,
era como si el mundo a mi alrededor también se llenara de más odio.
Como si hubiera una corriente constante y subyacente de odio
fluyendo a nuestro alrededor
y desbordándose cada vez más.
El lado positivo, creo,
es que el odio no era un problema exclusivamente mío,
que es el lado positivo más egoísta que pueda existir.
(Risas)
Porque ahora, en vez de tener que resolver mi propio odio y mi propia crueldad,
quería desentrañar todo un mundo de odio,
entenderlo y arreglarlo.
Así que hice lo que todo intelectual hace
cuando tiene un problema que quiere entender:
escribí un libro.
(Risas)
Un libro sobre el odio.
Alerta de "spoiler":
Estoy en contra.
(Risas)
En este punto, estarán pensando
"¿Por qué estás tan preocupada por el odio?
No odiabas a Vicky.
El acoso escolar no es odio".
Pero ¿es realmente así?
Gordon Allport,
el primer psicólogo en investigar el tema del odio a principio de 1900,
desarrolló lo que denominó una "escala de prejuicio".
En un extremo se encuentra el genocidio y otros tipos de violencia por prejuicio.
Y en el otro extremo
está la creencia de sentirse dentro de un grupo,
superiores a quienes están fuera del grupo,
o renuenciar a relacionarse socialmente con esos otros.
¿No es odio todo eso?
Es decir, no fue casualidad
que yo fuera una niña rica acosando a una niña pobre,
o que Vicky, según pude saber, terminara siendo homosexual.
Los niños pobres y homosexuales están más expuestos al acoso escolar,
aun por parte de niños que terminan siendo homosexuales.
Sé que pasaban muchas cosas en mi mentecilla de niña de 10 años.
No quiero decir que el odio fuese la única razón para acosar a Vicky
ni que yo era consciente de mi odio,
pero lo cierto es que las personas que discriminamos
con las políticas públicas en nuestra cultura
son las mismas que están más expuestas a ser acosadas en la escuela.
Esto no es mera coincidencia.
Es odio.
Y defino el odio en un sentido amplio
porque creo que tenemos un gran problema.
Y es necesario resolverlo a fondo, no solo los casos más extremos.
Por ejemplo, todos estamos de acuerdo con que manifestarse en las calles
en contra de los derechos de algunas personas
en razón del color de piel o del género
es odio, ¿verdad? Muy bien.
¿Qué pasa si creemos que ese grupo de gente es inferior,
pero no lo decimos?
¿Es odio?
¿O qué pasa si creemos que ese grupo de gente es inferior
pero no nos damos cuenta de que lo pensamos?
Lo que se conoce como prejuicio implícito.
¿Es odio?
Quiero decir, todos tienen la misma raíz
en los patrones históricos de racismo y sexismo
que han construido nuestra historia y aun infectan nuestra sociedad actual.
¿No es odio todo eso?
No digo que sean lo mismo,
como tampoco diría
que un acosador escolar sea igual de malo que un nazi,
así como ser un nazi no es igual que pegarle a un nazi.
(Risas)
Pero odiar a un nazi es odio también, ¿o no?
¿Qué pasa si odiamos a alguien que no es tan tolerante como uno?
Lo que yo aprendí
es que todos estamos en contra del odio
y todos pensamos que el odio es un problema.
Pensamos que es problema del otro,
no nuestro.
Ellos son los que odian.
Es decir, si pienso que las personas que no votaron como yo
son monstruos racistas e imbéciles que no merecen llamarse esdaounidenses,
está bien, no las estoy alabando,
lo admito.
(Risas)
No las odio, solo digo la verdad, ¿sí?
Incorrecto.
Todos odiamos.
Y no lo digo en un sentido abstracto o genérico.
Me refiero a todos nosotros,
a Uds. y a mí.
Esa superioridad de subirnos a un pedestal de moralina
para decir que los otros odian y nosotros no
es una manifestación de la verdadera raíz del odio,
de que nosotros somos esencialmente buenos y ellos no.
Esto es lo que debe cambiar.
Pues bien, para comprender y resolver el tema del odio,
leí tantos libros e investigaciones como pude,
pero también hablé con exnazis,
exterroristas,
exgenocidas seriales,
porque pensé que si ellos pudieron encontrar la manera de escapar al odio,
nosotros también podíamos.
Les contaré el caso de un exterrorista que entrevisté
en Cisjordania.
Cuando Bassam Aramin tenía 16 años, intentó explotar
un convoy miltar israelí con una granada.
Afortunadamente, no lo logró
pero todavía cumplía una condena de siete años en prisión.
En la cárcel, le mostraron una película sobre el Holocausto.
Hasta ese momento,
Bassam pensaba que el Holocausto era más bien un mito.
Quiso ver la película
porque pensó que disfrutaría con la muerte de los judíos.
Pero cuando vio lo que pasó realmente, se puso a llorar.
Y cuando salió de prisión
Bassam estudió para obtener su maestría en estudios sobre el Holocausto
y fundó una organización
en la que excombatientes palestinos e israelíes se reunían,
trabajaban en conjunto e intentaban encontrar intereses comunes.
Según palabras del mismo Bassam, odiaba a los israelíes,
pero al conocerlos, oír sus historias
y trabajar con ellos por la paz,
superó su odio.
Dice que aun hoy sigue sin guardarles rencor,
aun después de que los militares israelíes
mataran de un disparo a su hija de 12 años, Abir,
cuando iba a la escuela.
(Suspira)
Bassam llegó incluso a perdonar al soldado que mató a su hija.
Él me enseñó que ese soldado
era producto del mismo sistema del odio donde él estuvo.
Si un exterrorista...
si un terrorista puede aprender a despojarse del odio
e incluso perdonar cuando matan a su niño,
entonces nosotros podemos dejar
de menospreciarnos y deshumanizarnos entre nosotros.
Y les comento que las historias como Bassam están en todo el mundo,
y hay infinidad de estudios según los cuales
no estamos hechos ni destinados de manera alguna para odiar,
sino para que el mundo nos enseñe a odiar.
Les aseguro
que nadie sale del útero odiando a los negros ni a los republicanos.
No hay nada en nuestro ADN
que nos haga odiar a los musulmanes ni a los mexicanos.
Para bien o para mal,
todos somos producto de la cultura circundante.
Pero la buena noticia
es que somos nosotros mismos quienes hacemos la cultura,
lo cual significa que la podemos cambiar.
El primer paso es empezar a reconocer el odio que llevamos dentro.
Debemos reconocernos a nosotros mismos
y a nuestros pensamientos del odio en todas sus formas,
en todos nosotros.
Y debemos trabajar para cuestionar nuestras ideas y suposiciones.
No se hace de un día para el otro,
lo advierto:
es un viaje que dura toda la vida, pero debemos hacerlo.
Y lo segundo:
si queremos cuestionar el odio que hay en nuestra sociedad,
debemos promover políticas, instituciones y prácticas
que nos conecten como comunidades.
Literalmente, como los barrios y las escuelas integradas.
A propósito, ese es el motivo para apoyar la integración.
No solo porque es lo que se debe hacer,
sino porque la integración combate el odio sistemáticamente.
Estudios demuestran que si los adolescentes participan
en clases y actividades de integración racial,
reducen sus prejuicios raciales.
Y cuando los pequeños van a jardín de infantes y escuelas primarias
de integración racial,
construyen también menos prejuicios.
Pero lo cierto es que de muchas maneras y en muchos lugares del mundo,
estamos separados unos de otros.
En EE. UU., por ejemplo,
tres cuartos de la gente blanca no tienen amigos no blancos.
De manera que, además de promover esas soluciones proactivas,
lo otro que debemos hacer es erradicar el odio de las instituciones
y de las políticas que perpetúan la deshumanización, la diferencia,
la discriminación y el odio,
como los sistemas de acoso y abuso sexual en el trabajo,
o nuestro sistema de "justicia" penal
tan profundamente injusto y tendencioso en materia racial.
Es necesario cambiar eso.
Repito, no será de un día para el otro.
Pero debe ocurrir.
Y luego,
cuando nos unimos
en estos espacios de conexión,
facilitados por sistemas de conexión,
debemos cambiar la manera en que nos hablamos
y nos conectamos unos a otros.
Debemos relacionamos con generosidad y apertura mental,
bondad y compasión,
y no con odio.
Y eso es todo.
Es todo.
(Aplausos)
Lo resolví, ¿verdad?
Es así.
Pues sí,
hay otros detalles,
pero esto es lo que debemos hacer.
No es tan complicado, ¿o sí?
Pero no es fácil.
El odio que sentimos por algunos grupos de personas
en función de lo que son o lo que creen
está tan grabado en nuestra mente y en la sociedad
que parece inevitable
e imposible de cambiar.
El cambio es posible.
Y si no, veamos al terrorista que se transformó en activista por la paz,
o el acosador escolar que aprendió a disculparse ante su víctima.
Todo el tiempo que pasé viajando por el Medio Oriente y Ruanda
y por todo EE. UU.,
escuchando estas increíbles historias de gente en comunidades
que habían dejado atrás todo un pasado de odio,
todavía buscaba a Vicky.
Me costaba tanto encontrarla que contraté a un investigador privado,
que fue quien la encontró.
En cierto modo, digamos.
Lo cierto es que la persona que yo llamo Vicky
había intentado ocultar su identidad por todos los medios.
De todas maneras, un año después de empezar mi viaje,
le escribí una disculpa.
Y unos meses después,
me contestó.
(Suspira)
No voy a mentir,
quería su perdón.
Pero no me lo dio.
(Suspiro)
Vicky me dio una especie de perdón condicional.
Y me contestó esto:
"Mensajes como el tuyo no pueden absolverte de tus actos pasados.
La única manera de lograrlo es haciendo un mundo mejor,
evitando que otros se comporten de manera parecida
y fomentando la compasión".
Y Vicky tiene razón.
Por eso estoy aquí.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)